hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from defeated candidates
tournament 2021
our writer 2020 slash 21 edition uh it's
the current leader of the tournament
yani palmishi versus kiro alexenko who
is having an excellent tournament
considering he's the underdog here
and whatever he does uh well it's
basically only a plus for him
and uh young so far lost only one game
to maximize
in the previous half of the tournament
and kill alexenko so far with two losses
uh i don't know why uh for some reason
in the previous video i mentioned
that um uh ding lost a game to caruana
uh in the first half of the tournament
where it was in fact fabi who was the
game to ding
in the first half of the tournament it
was his only loss sometimes i
mix things up like that i i don't know
why it happens but uh
it's funny because in the video prior to
that i i you know uh
said it the correct way so sorry about
that sometimes my brain just does stuff
uh but getting back to this game it's
quite a nice one yep with the white
pieces
opens with c4 so he opts for the english
opening we have knight to f6
g3 now preparing to film get to the
light square bishop
e6 and now bishop to g2 we have d5
striking in the center and now knight to
f3
and here we have d captures on c4 so
grabbing that pawn but
uh you will win it at any point with for
example queen a4
check and then you're just gonna win the
pawn and this is exactly what nepal does
right away
queen a4 check and now about c6 and
bishop to d7 are
are played here but uh the knight b to
d7
is the absolute uh absolutely most
popular move here and this is what uh
alex anko goes for so here uh nipple
wins his pawn back we have queen
captures on c4
and now a6 we have queen back to c2
and now c5 striking the center so this
has all been played before
very very standard stuff we have knight
to c3
and now uh bishop to e7 bishop to e7 is
uh
uh well not a rare move but it's not
the uh you know the go-to move in this
position queen to
c7 for example much more uh or uh you
know
often uh and even rook to a7 just uh
preparing b5 and then you're going to
bring that rook into the game via the
seventh rank
uh getting that rook away from that a8
file so that
you can start expanding on the queen
side a bit more rapidly but okay
here alexandra goes for bishop to e7
both players castle we have castles
castles and
now d4 nepal strikes in the center we
have c
captures knight captures and now queen
to c7 we have rook to d1
now mobilizing all of his pieces he
still still needs to
develop the dark square bishop and the
rook on a1 and here there is one game
from 1999 where knight to b6 was played
but here we have rook to d8
and it is now already as of move 12 did
we have a completely new game
uh so let's see how nepal deals with it
he uh immediately goes bishop to e3 and
it it looks like kind of a position
where you'd expect something like e4
but no he plays bishop to e3 keeps his
pawn on e2
uh to be decided later what what to do
with it and it's
um well it could be very tricky if black
had a move like knight to g4 for example
it could be problematic however
uh this would just be losing for black
if you go for something like this
try and uh harass this bishop just
knight to d5 and now there's a double
attack on the queen
uh and after queen captures on c2 you
have this in between sufficient two
knight captures an e7 check king f8 and
now
knight captures on c2 you're gonna play
knight catchers on e3
knight captures king captures on e7 and
now rook a to c1
and okay it's not it's not a lost
position for black but it's
uh why it has all of the all of the
pieces developed the black still has so
you know a a lot of moves to play to get
back into the game so this is basically
what um
nepo is hoping for uh and he would be
very happy playing this position but
instead after this bishop to e3 we have
knight
to b6 uh and now comes rook
a to c1 of course you are very happy
with the doubling up on the c file the
queen on c7 is undefended
uh and here alexenko goes for e5 attacks
that knight here he wants it to move so
he can maybe trade some rooks along the
d
file and now knight to f5 an excellent
square for the knight and you're
basically asking are you interested in
giving up your bishop pair
uh which will increase of course the
activity of my queen and then
uh you know bad things that might happen
to you uh and here
the problem is if you go for something
like rook captures knight captures and
queen captures on c2 there's always the
in between
knight captures on e7 check king f8 and
now rook captures and c2
king captures and of course now the
knight on b6 hang so this is
uh only one of the issues with with the
knight being on b6 but okay
alex anko was ready to capture on f5
either way so here we have bishop
captures
uh instead of bishop captures on f5
bishop to f8 a nice slow move
also might be possible but then uh again
it's uh well it's it's a very
interesting position even ideas like
knight captures and g7 become possible
because then you just weaken the dark
squares completely for example bishop
captures queen to b3 now the
the rooks are really really strong here
and uh
well there's still pressure on this
knight there's a double attack on the
knight
and it's just a very very crazy position
for example rook captures knight
captures
now opens up a discovery still you're
attacking the the knight here and then
well anything could happen queen d8
uh we could capture on b6 for example
bishop captures but
then uh well the the game might continue
uh
in a lot of different ways for example
queen to d2 going after the
the rook here then queen c2 maybe we
trade queens and uh this is only one of
the
ways that uh you could play this uh for
example with black but instead after
this knight to f5
alexandre went for bishop captures on f5
he said this is uh
much better you know let's not over
complicate things
and now comes the queen captures on f5
and here nipple has some
one hour and 23 minutes on the clock
whereas alexenko has only 41 minutes on
the clock
uh and here we have knight to c4
and he spent some 20 minutes on this
move so now
uh we're only on move 16 and alexandra
is already below 20 minutes is
some 18 minutes on the clock uh it's a
very tricky position because
uh if you just try developing instead
you go instead of this you let's say you
go something like rook 8 to c8
uh you immediately get 95 and then
you're in trouble the queen is attacked
twice and you don't really have a good
response to this you also need to defend
the bishop on e7
so let's say queen d6 now you just play
bishop captures on b6
and what do you do here everything is
nicely defended you could trade once
here
captures captures and let's say knight
captures and e5 but then your rook hangs
bishop captures 98 bishop captures and
let's say queen d3 with a double attack
on the knight black is completely
destroyed here
so only one of the problems of black's
position and why it's so hard to find
the move so here alexenko played knight
to c4 instead
uh his idea was now if nipple persists
with knight to d5
he can go for knight characters on e3
with an attack on white's queen and now
if f
captures an e3 we're gonna play queen to
d6
and now okay we can trade let's say
knight captures queen capture so rook
captures rook captures
and then for example if queen captures
we can go g captures uh strengthening
the center and then bishop captures an
f7
uh we would get this position where yes
white is up upon but
it's very hard to say if you would be
able to actually do anything here the
bishops are of opposite colors
uh you would push but whether it would
be enough it's hard to say so instead
after knight the c4
uh even though alexandra spent some over
20 minutes deciding on this uh nipple
came back to the table and he
instantly played bishop to g5 he wasn't
interested in any
uh simplifications and now comes rook
captures on d1 again you can't really
bring the rook to c8 uh just yet because
now bishop
g5 introduced another threat into the
position and that's just cactus captures
and now
knights to d5 with a double attack here
queen to d6
and now bishop to e4 that's the stuff
attacking
h7 and there's no way of defending this
because if you ever play g6
then you lose the bishop on f6 so
there's that
so instead after bishop to g5 we have
rook captures on d1
makes sense you want to get the rook
away from the defense of
from the attack on the queen and now
comes
knight captures on d1 and this was a
very interesting decision i was
really patiently waiting to see whether
nipple captures with the knight or with
the rook
uh because both uh i guess have their
merits uh but nipple decided to go for
knight captures on the d1
still keeping an eye on the queen on c7
and now while you should definitely move
the queen here with something like queen
to d8 add more support to the f6
knight here uh here rook to d8 was
played
and now that's a bit of a problem
because now nipple has a very very clear
idea of
what he wants to do so feel free to
pause the video and try to find the
winning idea for nipple
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on helping nepo
stay in the lead of the candidates
tournament and maybe even challenge
magnus for the throne and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show
it's bishop captures an f6 yep that's
that's how it's done bishop captures and
now the move we've already encountered
not in this exact same move order but
we've encountered it bishop to e4 and
this is now a huge problem and you can
see how difficult the position is and uh
alexenko spent almost all of his time
trying to decipher the intricacies of
the position but it simply wasn't enough
and nipple basically spent a few minutes
uh only
so far so that's that's how well
prepared nepo is
we have queen to a5 of course you cannot
do anything here i mean
at g6 you just lose the bishop uh really
makes no sense
uh so here he tried queen to a5 trying
to go for this
uh let's say queen captures an h7 king
of f8 and now if rook captures on c4 we
could play rook captures on d1 with
king g2 now g6 the guard the h8 square
but still after bishop captures on b7
it's uh
it's such a powerful position for white
it's hard to imagine that black would be
able to get out of this you can't really
do anything
if the queen captures then you allow the
rook to come to c7 put pressure here
uh not a lot for uh for black to do here
but nippo said
uh i'm not giving you any chances on
playing knight to c3 just nicely
defending everything
and there's always uh well queen
captures on h7 you can't really do
anything about this so here
alexander played king to f8 not allowing
the capture to come with
check but again nepo uh not in a rush
goes for knight to d5
now again uh put more pressure on f6 and
just ask
what do you want to do also there's now
an attack on the knight on c4
so alexenko needs to deal with all of
this and there is the possibility of
just
capturing here for example captures
captures and captures
uh grabbing two pieces for the rook the
problem is queen to c8
check nicely connects with the knight
here and then after you defend
we can just capture it and then okay
black is now just down too much material
and of course
lost so instead we have b5 here
uh he just defends his knight on c4 and
here alexenko has only two minutes left
on the clock whereas nipple has uh
or like an hour and 20 minutes i think
an hour and 17
17 minutes was at the exact time
and here he goes for the h7 pawn because
there's no more way to to improve the
position you could go for something like
rook to c3 to completely cut off the
queen from d1 square
but he deems it unnecessary he goes
queen captures on h7
and now uh he allows uh he allows a
trick here for example captures captures
and queen to d2 going after both the
knight and the rook on c1
but he calculates precisely with rook
captures on d5
bishop captures queen to d2 now
attacking the rook and the bishop
and of course now rook captures on c4
that was the plan
uh we have b captures on c for grabbing
the rook and now i know a lot of you
want to capture this pawn but of course
if we did that then
queen c1 check and we lose the bishop so
hopefully
not all too many of you wanted to grab
that pawn
instead nipple just played e4 here and
the bishop is nicely defended on d5
also possible there there's like a
forcing line here queen to h but if you
don't have to calculate uh if there are
more
good moves there then maybe it's not
necessary but i will show it however in
case nipple messes this up so you guys
know that
there was another way to do this k7 now
queen to a8 keeping
uh an eye on the bishop also keeping an
eye on this entire diagonal here
and the black here would have to go for
queen captures and try and
push this pass pawn to victory queen
captures on a6
c3 now and now queen to c6 and
that's just it now if for example c2 we
get queen to c7 check and you're getting
checkmated king e8 bishop c6 check
and you have to move to f8 queen to see
it check king e7 now we're going to
deliver check again
here and this is now checkmate so this
is a kind of the idea
uh behind this whole maneuver here uh
but okay he played e4
uh also also works we have queen
captures on b2 now again ready to push
this pawn to victory
and only now queen to h8 king is seven
and
now queen to c8 with with a very similar
idea
uh if the pawn is pushed then we
introduce the
queen to c7 uh checkmating sequence
so uh we have queen to b6 guarding uh
against queen to c7 check but now just
queen captures on c4
uh and here alexenko was uh getting
extremely low on time
and he didn't have all that uh many
moves to try
one valiant attempt here was definitely
king to f8 because uh
you're already down upon and you're
going to lose this pawn there's no
question about it but king to f8
at least allows some counter play
because here if white persists with
bishop captures on f7 you can play queen
b5
and now you get this position where you
either trade and then we go into an end
game of opposites colored bishops that
maybe
you can hold maybe it's some sort of a
crazy position that is standable
but also if something like queen to e6
then you also might run into a trap like
this queen b1
check king g2 and now queen captures
here so
now of course you you always have uh
some sort of a perpetual going on here
uh but okay after queen captures on c4
we did not see king to f8
although it's uh probably it wouldn't be
enough but it was it was black's
best attempt uh queen to b5 was played
and this was played with like i said
some 20 seconds on the clock here
as you can see uh pushing that uh uh
queen all the way to b5 uh with 21
seconds on the clock i think when he
actually pressed that it was 20 seconds
and you can see in apple uh with one one
hour and five minutes on the clock
that's
uh that's very very impressive uh but
yeah queen to be unlike for grishok who
has uh you know spent more more than uh
all of that time on just one move in
this round but we will
we're probably going to get to that so
queen to b5 and here we have queen to c7
check queen to d7 and here
uh uh let me just check if i have the
the moves correctly
uh yes indeed after this queen blocked
we have queen to the
uh queen to c5 with check and it was in
this position that kiddle alexinko
resigned the game as
there is nothing uh there is nothing
more to be done here
uh you can't really block if you block
then you allow for example queen
uh queen 36 you're going to play queen
to a7 with
check now this pawn falls uh also if you
just block then we might even consider
okay
we're not really interested in capturing
the queen for example captures captures
and captures
but sorry captures captures and captures
uh but
just for example capturing an a6 is just
i mean
enough now we're up two pawns and two
points is way way
uh enough to in an end game like this we
can just push our pass pawn to victory
and that's just it
and other than that there really isn't
all that much uh
all that much you can do here i can't
really do
do any good moves with with the king but
whatever you if you go here again queen
a5 check can pick up the pawn so it
doesn't really matter
and of course we do not want to play
king to e8 because then just bishop the
c6 will uh win the queen and
there's no no more chances here and
alexenko still had
some 10 moves to reach time control he
would constantly be playing an increment
he didn't want to you know play a
nonsense move so he just
thought it'd be it'd be better if if he
just resigned there after queen the c5
check
which you did and as yannipon she was
leading the tournament uh
you know while entering round 10 uh he
was leading the tournament by half a
point he is still
the undisputed leader of the tournament
and so far uh the challenger
to magnus carlsen if he can continue uh
playing for the rest of the tournament
with
this uh you know uh uh you know
relentlessness
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh a tough break for carol
but
he he is playing the the leader of the
tournament and he like i said
anything he accomplishes here is a great
victory for him but of course there will
be bumps along the road
uh i would like to thank uh crank phil
oscarson uh sushil kramhar
philip kompaus uh philip kompal mario
and sinosa and
israel stones for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
candidates tournament checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chess world
uh so thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day